wie schauen Sie darauf
vor allem in Bayern da ist die Welt ja
weitestgehend in Ordnung wie sie immer
wieder Beton ist jetzt Frankreich aber
wir denken alle Neuköllner
Silvesternacht beispielsweise auch da
hatten wir auch in dieser Sendung genau
diese Debatten wie kann es sein dass ein
Teil junger Menschen offensichtlich
keine keine Beziehung zu diesem Staat
hat ja ich glaube das ist der springende
Punkt ist wenn sich ein Teil der
Bevölkerung nicht mehr mit dem Staat
nicht mehr mit der Gesellschaft
identifiziert vielleicht danach große
kulturelle Unterschiede sind
glaubensmäßige archaische Strukturen
mitbringen und eben nicht bereit die
sich in demokratische Strukturen zu
integrieren dann kann das schief laufen
und da braucht man gar nicht so weit
gehen wir hatten die Krawallen auch in
Essen wo sie ihn libanesische und
syrische Gangs zu Hunderten auf beiden
Seiten geblügelspiel
Friedensrichter diese Herrschaften
wieder zur Mäßigung gebracht hat nicht
zunächst mir die deutsche Justiz und
Polizei die am Tage lang sich ja
verprügelt und haben sich hier bekämpft
jetzt sind es Gott sei Dank erst
hunderte auf beiden Seiten aber lass das
auf beiden Seiten 1.000 oder 10.000
Design und dann kommt am Ende in
friedensrichtung sagt du kriegst jetzt
drei Autos und Du darfst dieses Gebiet
immer beten weil die wollen dort Geld
verdienen mit Restaurants und
Prostitution und auch die darfst du
nicht rein dann sind das Parallelwelten
dass man die heimische Justiz nicht mehr
anerkennt dass die Polizei die Lage
nicht mehr im Griff hat und wenn die
Polizei da rein ginge vielleicht die
politische Rückendeckung fehlt und dann
jetzt bringen wir das trotzdem auf den
Punkt wenn es vorher heißt noch mit der
Staatsbürgerschaft und so weiter wir
jetzt schon diesen Syrern die seit 8
Jahren bei uns sind die Deutschen Pässe
aushändigen und die sagen sehr großer
Fehler dieser Ampel dass man jetzt
einbürger bevor die Integration
funktioniert hat und das ist wohl auch
ein Punkt gewesen dass die leberwesen
sich dort jetzt schon beschweren und
sagen die Syrer kriegen schon den
deutschen Pass und wir nicht also nach
fünf Jahren kriegen die den deutschen
sind aber in diesem Gangs organisiert
die kriegst du nicht mehr los das ist
dann ein deutscher Staatsbürger selbst
wenn du raus bekommst das ist der Game
Boss dann hast du gesehen da also diese
Dinge sind bei uns nicht weit weg
natürlich ganz andere Dimension andere
historischer Hintergrund kolonialer
Hintergrund ich glaube das ist
tatsächlich Gesellschaft haben wir auch
schon in Ansätzen und diesen Orten diese
Syrer haben sie gerade gesagt völlig
interessant die diese Syrer alle so nein
aber die Syrer die seit
2015 bei uns sind die unter Merkel
Thomas gekommen sind das ist jetzt auch
die Jahre her die bekommen momentan sehr
großzügig die deutschen Pässe sind aber
noch nicht unbedingt im Arbeitsmarkt
integriert und ich sehe das als
politischen Fehler hier zu schnell
dehnen im Pass hinterher zu laufen ohne
zu erwarten dass die vorher einen
Arbeitsplatz haben sich integriert haben
da sagen die dann dann geht das mit sehr
sehr schwierig
ein paar Jahre länger müssen die hier
sein und müssen integriert sein und
müssen ihren Lebensunterhalt selbst
bestreiten können das erwartet man heute
nicht mehr und das ist für mich ein zu
liberales aushändigen unserer Pässe noch
mal sie sagten gerade die Formulierung
fand ich interessanter läuft diese Ampel
läuft diesen Syrern mit dem deutschen
Pass hinterher jetzt kommen wir jetzt
dreimal drehen und dann ist dieser
besonders böses Wort gewesen ich sage
aber anders nein aber sie sie sie machen
das häufiger ich habe das ja auch
beobachtet sie hauen einen raus
ganz kurz sie haben einen raus und dann
sagen sie da wird dann direkt wieder das
Wort dem Mund umgedreht hatte jeder
gehört was sie gesagt hat mich jetzt
noch mal um diese also in der im Befund
in der Diagnose haben sie ja an einigen
Stellen definitiv recht wir haben das
Thema gerade letzte Woche hier auch in
der Sendung ausführlich behandelt und
machen das auch immer wieder und ich
teile auch ihre Auffassung wenn sie
sagen wir tun uns als Land
offensichtlich schwer über Probleme die
ist ganz offenkundig bei der Integration
gibt ehrlich und klar zu sprechen aber
diese Formulierung diese Syrien im
deutschen Pass hinterher gelaufen finden
Sie das ist eine adäquate Formulierung
oder ist das eine die dazu angetan ist
wieder sozusagen dem affenzucker zu
geben noch mal jetzt hier eine Straße
also ich glaube es geht um die
Sachverhalte und die Sachverhalte sind
in meinen Augen politisch völlig falsch
aufgehängt und jetzt können wir sagen
aber sie denken jetzt schon wieder von
der inhaltlichen Debatte ab ins wöring
hat dir diese wieder gesagt nicht diese
Tiere diese beiden Buchstaben haben ja
aber diese Syrien haben mir unterstelle
ich würde pauschal sagen
interpretiert ich habe nicht gesagt
diese
dieser Welt sondern diese Syrer die 15
gekommen genau
sind die von 2015 denen die Ampel jetzt
mit dem Pass hinterher läuft das war der
zweite Test nicht genau in dem sie die
Einbürgerung hier in meinen Augen
deutlich zu liberal aufhängt und nicht
sagt das ist am Ende des
Integrationsprozesses die Auszeichnung
für dich wenn du dich integrierst wenn
du einen Arbeitsplatz findest wenn du
dich selber über Wasser halten kannst
dann bekommst du zur Krönung mit
Handschlag deinen Pass verlieren du bist
hier mit Staatsbürger in Bayern wird es
hier zelebriert sogar der wird
zelebriert neue Bürger Aufnahme das ist
ja feierlicher Akt aber nicht aus der
mal schnell aufs Amt geht holt seinen
Pass ab und sagt dann zum Libanesen ich
habe ihn doch noch nicht und er ist
vielleicht genauso im Bürgergeld noch
drin
als ob alle den deutschen Pass haben
wollten es ist im Grunde ja eher so dass
wir eigentlich relativ niedrige
Einbürgerungszahlen haben momentan
noch natürlich weil wir jetzt auch neue
zugangszahlen hatten aber es ist ja
jetzt nur nicht so als ob alles Syrer
den
2015/2016 gekommen sind jetzt sich in
Schlachten mit Libanesen oder mit wem
auch immer bleiben
in Essen haben wir den Fakt das hunderte
Syrer auf der einen Seite mit 100
Libanesen auf der anderen Seite sich mit
Dachlatten und so weiter
über die Mütze weil vielleicht
verstanden werden könnte dass er sagt
alles wieder Reifen mit allem also wo
wollen wir denn hin wollen wir die Dinge
beim Namen nennen oder wollen wir werden
führen
das interessant sie sie schreiben viel
sie sind ein Mann des Wortes
es ist das egal wie man redet natürlich
nicht egal auch im politischen Umgang
nicht egal welche Wörter man wählt ich
meine sind natürlich als Vertreter einer
konservativen Partei in einer
schwierigen Situation gerade weil es am
am rechten Rand eine Partei gibt die
gerade wahnsinnige umfragezahlen hat ich
weiß noch nicht ob das hilft die Sprache
dieser Leute zu übernehmen und das ist
dann doch immer wieder der Fall also das
unter verrutscht was und ich finde das
nicht unerheblich wie man über sowas
redet das ist sehr sehr wichtig und
beschreibt sie durch den Sorgfalt
zwischen diesen Syrern und diesen diesen
in der in der Semantik verlieren er
hätte ich eine ganz andere Frage wie
würden sie das denn lösen
indem ich von Anfang an genauer
hinschaue erstens einmal war es ein
Fehler dass wir 20 15 ja eine zu große
Zahl haben kommen lassen
okay also Merkel hat den massiven Fehler
gemacht zu viele Leute hier kommen zu
lassen mit gefälschten Pässen oder ohne
Pässe mit falschen Herkunftsangaben und
so weiter wir haben es bis heute nicht
geschafft nach 8 Jahren einen Großteil
dieser Menschen in Arbeitsprozesse zu
bringen und knapp die Hälfte dieser
Syrer von 20 15 sind heute im Bürgergeld
das waren die junge arbeitsfähige
Menschen ja die Hälfte noch nicht in
Ordnung
unsere Arbeitsmarkt und
Integrationspolitik die eben nicht in
die Arbeitsverhältnisse zu bringen und
jetzt rutschen die in Clans ab teilweise
jetzt nicht alle 1,5 Millionen aber
sondern eben dort so und so viele und
dann schaut der Staat wieder Kritik des
tagelang nicht im Griff bis ein
friedensrichterpräsident in Bayern
werden
meinen sie wieder hier wieder Kanzler
wird mache ich
ministerpräsidentschaft
so ist nichts was mir Angst macht also
ich habe nichts gegen die Bayern
angenommen Sie sind jetzt im politischen
Verantwortung und jetzt Überraschung sie
sind im politischer Verantwortung wie
würden Sie denn machen
wenn jemand die erste Straftat bekommt
wir die Strafe auf den Fuß folgen lassen
und nicht hier zuschauen bis jemand 10
12 15 Straftaten bis jemand zum
Serienstraftäter wird und dann immer du
du und dann ist die Mama Schuld und dann
ist die Oma Schuld aber nie die ja
selber und am Ende ist Deutschland
Schuld sondern wir treffen den
Einzelfall raus und sagen er wird jetzt
hier juristisch ja
so in Griff bekommen dass wir möglichst
Kriminalität vermeiden schon sehr in
München haben wir einen höheren
Ausländeranteil wie in vielen anderen
Großstädten Deutschlands haben trotzdem
den Großteil dieser Bürger in Arbeit und
haben eine deutlich niedrigere
Kriminalität also es kommt schon darauf
an wie man mit der Situation umgeht ob
man dort auch genauer hinschaut denn
wenn das Kind mal im Brunnen gefallen
ist man ist zu spät und dazu braucht die
Polizei auch die Rückendeckung der
Politik und die hat sie in Bayern und in
vielen anderen Bundesländern ist ja
immer die Polizei schuld wenn was schief
läuft und der Richter traut sich immer
also das ist schon wichtig der Staat
muss konsequent Straftaten verhindern
und die Leute in Ordnung bringen ja wenn
ich den Satz nur sagen darf
das wir jetzt wirklich schneller schauen
müssen dass wir diese Leute in
Arbeitsprozesse bringen und darum bin
ich überzeugt dass das Bürgergeld dieses
lieberale vergeben das Bürgergeldes auch
an junge arbeitsfähige ein großer Fehler
sondern wir müssen versuchen noch
intensiver diese Menschen wie in Bayern
aber ich glaube bei uns immer über Herz
Bürgergeld genauso gibt in Arbeit zu
bringen dann werden die in der
Gesellschaft besser integriert sind
mindestens acht Stunden sinnvoll
beschäftigt dann passiert weniger als
wenn wir wegschauen wegschauen
wegschauen
am Ende ist der Polizist Schulter
Richter Schuld Deutschland Schuld und am
Ende beklagen alle was ist da schief
gelaufen
also ich ich weiß nicht wie es Ihnen
geht Frau Münch aber ich ich tue mich
wahnsinnig schwer mit dieser sehr
generalistischen Ansage und ich frage
mich gerade die ganze Zeit wissen sie
auch in Bayern ist es ja so ohne viele
Zuwanderer würde auch ihr schönes Bayern
schon lange nicht mehr funktioniert
meine Frage ist nur haben Sie eine Idee
davon wie das für die klingt für die
vielen vielen anderen die morgens
aufstehen die wahnsinnig hart arbeiten
die teilweise zwei drei Jobs
gleichzeitig machen die genau das andere
versuchen von dem was sie gerade
beschrieben haben die versuchen
möglichst schnell Teil dieses Landes zu
werden die auf deutsche Kinder aufpassen
die bei der Müllabfuhr arbeiten die auch
interessanterweise deutsche
Polizeibeamte sind in Neuköllner
Silvester nach waren ganz viele
Polizisten Beamte mit
Migrationshintergrund die ist da
bestimmt sagen
wie wie wie was glaubst
mich nicht denn das sind genau die dass
sie mir jetzt sagen ich hätte was gegen
die Ausländer oder die würden uns auch
unser System
ich welche Angst haben Sie denn von mir
müssen Sie keine Angst haben weil ich
einfach merkt dass sie mir das Wort nein
sie sind wahnsinnig misstrauisch ja weil
sie weil sie merken dass man mit der Art
und Weise wie sie reden kann man was
anfangen das merken soll doch ich sage
interessant was da gerade passiert ich
habe das Gefühl sie sie unterstellen mir
dass ich ähnlich ähm unterwegs bin wie
sie auch sie nehmen sich fünf Fakten
zusammen schrauben sie sozusagen dass
das dann in einen knackiger spannender
Satz dabei rauskommt und sie haben das
Gefühl das könnte ich möglicherweise
auch ich könnte das machen
gewonnen haben was daraus zu drehen habe
ich gesagt auf was will er den raus und
jetzt gebe ich Ihnen ganz kurz die
Antwort auf die Frage was diese sagen
und der Ampel die allen
mittlerweile auf mich zu und sagen wir
wünschen uns das auch die anderen
arbeiten müssen auch der türkische
Anweisung sagt zu mir ich will nicht
dass Syrer oder meine Landsleute wie
auch immer im Bürgergeld ist und uns
diskreditiert als die Ausländer sondern
die die bei uns ordentlich arbeiten und
sich ordentlich Benehmen die sind
mittlerweile eher enttäuscht über die
deutsche Politik dass wir zuschauen wie
einige aus dem Ruder laufen und sagen
daraus entwickelt sich eine Anti
Ausländer Stimmung das ist der Punkt die
sind gerade ganz ehrlich
nein doch wo ist der Beweis der sage ich
Ihnen ja wenn Sie wenn Sie sagen also
zwei Sachen sie haben Recht mit dem
Befund wenn sie sagen wir sind unfassbar
schlecht bei der in Situation in den
Arbeitsmarkt da sind wir schlecht ist
eine der vielen Widersprüchen deutscher
anwanderungspolitik wir haben jedes Jahr
Rekord Migration
mehrere Großstädte wenn man großstaat ab
100.000 Einwohner sozusagen definiert
kommen zu unserem wir sind sehr sehr
schlecht die Leute in den Arbeitsmarkt
zu kriegen
mein Problem ist wenn sie sagen 50
Prozent es sind eher mehr die Arbeiten
sagen wir mal 30 Prozent der
erwerbsfähigen sind nicht im
Arbeitsmarkt 40%, wie viele sind knapp
50% derer die 20 15 gekommen sind unter
mir das sozusagen die Hälfte
genau
sagen okay der Sound ja das bedeutet ja
umgekehrt das ungefähr 50% im
Arbeitsmarkt sind jeder zweite arbeitet
heißt das übersetzt so das zweite ist
ich habe vor einiger Zeit hier ein
interessantes Gespräch gehabt von sich
herausstellte wir beklagen diese
Zustände häufig müssen dann aber auch
sagen deutsche Bürokratie ist unfähig
Leute in den Arbeitsmarkt zu bringen wir
verlangen von Menschen zum Teil ein
polizeiliches Führungszeugnis die aus
Syrien hergekommen sind verlangen ein
polizeiliches Führungszeugnis vom
Polizeistaat
ist immer ganz ehrlich jemand der ein
Führungszeugnis von Assad mir auf den
Tisch legt den will ich nicht haben der
will ich niemals anstellen
sie wir stehen uns selber im Weg als
Deutschland
Kritik gerade gehört irgendwie und sehr
wenig irgendwie an der deutschen beraten
Leute leben nach wie vor in
flüchtlingsunterkünften wo die
Integration schwer fällt das ist ja auch
ein ganz großes Problem dass wir die
Leute da nicht rausbringen aus diesen
Unterkünften aus diesem sammeln
unterkünftig durchaus in Häusern wenn
ein Bürgermeister noch genügend Häuser
findet aber wie gesagt noch acht Jahren
komme jetzt sagen wie er ist schuld dass
die noch acht Jahren noch nicht mal in
einem Gasthaus bedienen können oder in
der Küche mitarbeiten auch aufs
Bürgergeld weil das ja noch gar nicht so
lange was erzählen sie da das war vorher
eben war vorher was Hartz 4 ja jetzt ist
Bürgergeld
das noch lockerer
recht aber bitte lass uns doch versuchen
nicht in Arbeit bekommen und kriegen es
mit Bürgergeld jetzt zweimal nicht in
Ordnung
ja wir haben gerade geklärt was
sozusagen die die die verschiedenen
Perspektiven auf das Thema sind und es
ist komplett ich habe was was würden Sie
sagen einfacher was ist ihre Definition
von Demokratie was ist für sie eine
Demokratie Demokratie ist Politik im
Sinne der Bevölkerung zu machen von der
Bevölkerung legitimiert macht das Volk
ist das Volk hat die Macht das Volk
übergibt die Macht mal in einer
repräsentativen Demokratie für eine
gewisse Zeit es gibt aber auch Basis dem
statischere Ansätze wie in der Schweiz
und ich sage ganz ehrlich auch wir
Freien Wähler um einen sehr
basisdemokratischen Ansatz sind sehr
stark in den Kommunen wir haben schon
viele Volksbegehren gemacht wir wollen
eine Direktwahl des Bundespräsidenten
und ich sage die Politik muss sich
regelmäßig rückkoppeln zur Bevölkerung
und nicht nach dem Motto das ist ja die
Debatte gewesen und heizungsgesetz
einmal an der Macht dann kann ich vier
Jahre tun was ich will ich bin ja
gewählt und regiert vielleicht sogar
gegen die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung 80%
sagen heizungsgesetz Unsinn egal wir
haben die parlamentarische Mehrheit wird
ziehen das jetzt durch mit dem Ergebnis
dass die Bevölkerung sich nicht mehr
abgeholt fühlen das heißt und dann ist
das keine Demokratie mehr für das ist
noch eine demokratieform mal aber
die Staatsform und so weiter von dem
redet man nicht aber die Vorgehensweise
ist in meinen Augen Demokratie ich habe
ausdrücklich gesagt natürlich ist das
noch eine Demokratie auf die Staatsform
aber das Vorgehen ist in meinen Augen
nicht mehr richtig ich nehme sie ernst
ich hören genau zu ja
sowieso ganz kurz wenn du einmal
verstehen was für sie Demokratie
haben ist nur noch formal Demokratie
stimmt doch nicht ich habe gesagt wir
sind natürlich
ehrlich gesagt ihre Interpretation
ich habe jetzt den Bogen im heizgesetz
okay also nochmal sie haben gesagt es
ist formal eine Demokratie
in Berlin
gefragt ob ich das noch als Demokratie
sehe dann soll ich ja formal die
Staatsform jawohl vom aber die
Vorgehensweise die Ampel ist in diesem
Punkt für mich undemokratisch so wenn
sie gegen die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung
Politik machen okay
aber auf Dauer bei den Regierten und
sagen die da oben noch ein anderes Thema
mit dem Satz noch nicht fertig sie haben
die Analyse begonnen da waren noch nicht
fertig ich hab gesagt nein
Demokratie und die regieren gegen die
Mehrheit und damit bin ich der
Überzeugung läuft das nicht mehr richtig
die müssen sich wieder zurückkommen was
will die Gefühle verstanden
formale Demokratie
Demokratie ich meine womit der Aiwanger
also ich meine Aiwanger bezieht sich
jetzt auf den institutionenapparat auf
die Prozesse dass das alles
Institutionen
natürlich hat der Aiwanger Recht das
findet eine Rückkoppelung statt ganz
klar da hat er recht wir haben übrigens
eine freiheitliche rechtsstaatliche
Demokratie es geht ja nicht immer nur um
Mehrheiten sondern es muss ja auch
rechtsstaatlich Minderheitenschutz und
so weiter abgesichert sein aber
natürlich bedeutet das jetzt nicht dass
eine Regierung im ständigen Einklang mit
der Bevölkerung sein muss wir haben im
Unterschied zu einem früheren
bayerischen Ministerpräsidenten der von
der Koalition mit den Bürgern gesprochen
hat es ist jetzt nicht so dass es immer
hundertprozentig deckungsgleich ist wenn
es nicht immer deckungsgleich ist da
haben wir eine sogenannte Fragen und
regieren einfach nach meinungsfragen
zeitliche Gewaltenteilung wir haben eine
beschränkte Amtszeit wir haben
beschränkte Regierungszeiten und dann
wird sich das rächen aber eine Politik
die ständig nur das machen würde
was sie im Grunde demoskopisch abfragt
das ist nicht mein Verständnis von
natürlich ist es richtig es ist
demokratisch aber es ist keine
handlungsfähige Politik da einfach nur
das machen sie auch nicht also das ist
ja nur himmelweiterunterschied ob ich
immer ständig mich rückkoppele oder ob
ich so sehen den Auges gegen 80 Prozent
der Bevölkerung regiert
also das hat funktioniert
auch aber was doch funktioniert hat ist
dass die Bundesregierung offensichtlich
begriffen hat ein bisschen länger dazu
gebraucht zugegebenermaßen aber sie hat
doch begriffen und ich glaube da werden
nicht meine Erdinger Rede notwendig
gewesen dass es so nicht funktioniert
und sie hat sich korrigiert wobei sie
etwas korrigiert hat was noch überhaupt
nicht
beschlossen war also insofern
für mich ein ein ganz normaler Prozess
gewesen der die Ampel ausgesprochen viel
Lehrgeld hat bezahlen lassen ich meine
wer ist denn vor allem gestraft worden
die ampelregierung also insofern hat
doch alles funktioniert weil sie noch
Hause gekommen sind nachdem sie in
Berlin im Kabinett des durchgewunken
hatten dann sind es zu Hause von den
Waldbauern den Bürgern von der eigenen
Mann
gestritten
oder diese Entwicklung wurde erst dann
korrigiert als die Öffentlichkeit wie
auch immer fragen welchen beiträder
ist Demokratie für sie dann wenn etwas
korrigiert wird was ihnen nicht passt na
sondern einfach die Demokratie dann weg
wenn in Berlin jemand regiert er ihnen
nicht passt dann die Demokratie Gefahren
ganz im gegen unintelligible ich glaube
dass das eher auf die Ampel zutrifft die
sagt ich habe jetzt in jeder vielleicht
folgen Sie mir ganz kurz ein kleines
sympathisches Gedankenspiel sie sind ja
sehr schnell im Kopf wenn jetzt 80
Prozent in Bayern sagen würden Gendern
ist eine richtig gute Sache was wollen
wir dagegen kaum mehr ankämpfen egal
auch nicht egal dann würde ich sagen ich
bin zwar jetzt in einer anderen
vielleicht in einer Minderheiten
Position ich kann jetzt nichts mehr
gewinnen sonst werde ich überrollt aber
ist gefällt mir weiterhin nicht das war
vielleicht beim Impfen der Vergleich da
war ja in der absoluten Minderheit
plötzlich alle Medien haben gesagt man
wer sich nicht Stellvertreter
Ministerpräsident dieser schlechtes
Beispiel und am Ende muss ich am Ende
das war eben die Behauptung
also vielleicht nicht mehr für die
Mehrheit Frage sind dann ein schlechtes
Beispiel
Medien haben gesagt
und ich gebe Ihnen jetzt die Antwort sie
sind doch also sie sind doch ein
Bauernkinder und ich quasi auch oder wir
reden doch gerade aus also wenn ich sie
gerade aus Frage ob sie ein Vorbild sind
dann stellvertretender bayerischer
Ministerpräsident dann gibt es ja nur
zwei Möglichkeiten entweder ja oder nein
welche nehmen Sie
für einen Großteil ja aber nie für alle
nicht jeder ist für alle ein Vorbild
deswegen gibt es eine Demokratie warten
Sie nicht klar darauf vereinbarer wenn
sie wieder irgendwo in
Gesprächen zu reden
wo der Hase gerade lang läuft wir hatten
bei der letzten Wahl 11,6% jetzt kann
ich nicht für mich in Anspruch nehmen
ich bin ein Vorbild für 100 % Bayern
sondern ich bin eben ein Vorbild für
meine Wählerschaft und ein paar drüber
hinaus stellvertretender was ist hier
Demokratie Verständnis finde ich
interessant sie sind als
stellvertretender bayerischer
Ministerpräsident nur das Vorbild für
ihre eigene nein nein nein ich werde nur
von diesen Leuten als Vorbild gesehen
alle werden mich nicht als Vorbild sehen
jetzt mittlerweile deutlich nicht das
Thema verstehen genau also nochmal wir
hatten vor kurzem eine Umfrage dann
irgendwie 45 oder 48% dabei und sagt der
gute Politik also wenn ich jetzt aber
sagen würde ich bin aber Stellvertreter
das ist nicht die Schweigen der große
Mehrheit von der sie gerne sprechen
deswegen habe ich gesagt ich bin nicht
für alle das Vorbild sondern es gibt
heute grüne oder Rechtsaußen die sagen
eigentlich ist nicht unser Vorbild aber
in gewisser Teil sagt der findet den
Album richtig aber eben nicht alle dass
wir Angst haben alle müssen mich toll
finden Minderheit hinter sich
schau mal wenn die nächsten Wahl